Democrats are calling in their closer
when it comes to Georgia. Former President
Obama is going to be there
campaigning today
for Senator Raphael Warnock.
Obama is already
headlining Warnock's
closing ad campaign ahead of Tue
runoff election
against Republican
challenger Herschel Walker.
Georgia serious times
call for special leaders
leaders you can trust
leaders who are driven
by something bigger than politic
That's why you need to reelect m
and your senator.
Reverend Raphael Warnock,
The question is whether or not
that message is appealing to vot
CNN's Ivan
McKenna is live on the ground in
You have been following this rac
incredibly closely.
What are you hearing from voters
Because over a million of them
have already voted
in these early days of voting.
Well, good morning, Kaitlan.
I want to begin with the Obama v
because when he was here
just about a month ago,
it was the most fired up
that I have seen.
Georgia Democrats
he was over in College Park.
The line stretched around the ar
And when you talk
about runoff elections,
it is principally a turnout game
Which side can turn out the most
It makes a lot of sense for him
for them
the campaign to be calling him b
to really energize the Democrati
I would imagine
we are going to hear from him
a lot of what he said just four
when he essentially argued
that Herschel Walker was a great
football player, but not in a po
to serve in the United States Se
And so when it comes to the vote
there are those 200,000 voters
who did vote for the Republican
just a few weeks ago.
But did not vote
for the Republican Senate candid
I know that they've been trying
for them.
Is Herschel Walker out on the ro
What is his schedule
looking like in these last few d
Both of the candidates
have very busy schedules.
And you are right now
both sides
trying to capture those moderate
As I've been out on the trail, t
speaking to people
I was at a
Latino for Warnock event last ni
talking about star power with Ob
Tessa Thompson and America
Ferrera were there.
But as I was speaking to voters
it seems as though both sides re
their minds made up.
One woman told me
that she is actually more progre
than Senator Warnock,
but supports him and believes
he does a good job
of appealing to moderates
in this Southern state.
Meanwhile, Herschel Walker suppo
tell me that
they think
that the national media
underestimates him
and that the national media
also under
estimates the ground game
that Republicans have in this st
Take a listen to what I'm hearin
Being out here to see Senator Wa
and having him kind of be
part of the voice
that we we've been wanting for s
here in Atlanta,
when Herschel decided to run for
it was a no brainer for us.
We don't know his opponent,
but we do know Herschel
So there are two days
left of early voting in this sta
and tomorrow.
And then, of course,
our folks can vote on
election day on December six.
Take one.
And everyone is looking to see
what will happen on Tuesday.
50 or 51 seats for Democrats.
So thanks so much to the